вали
і
відві в ефірі
Щиро вітаю всіх на нашому онлайнвебінарі
ментально здоров'я дітей під час війни
цей вебінар організований міністерством
освіти та науки України спільно з
дитячим фондом онiceф Україні громадську
організацію рух олексаandдрапедано
junніor та за сприяння всеукраїнської
програми ментального здоров'я Ти як щиро
вдячни всім освітянам хто приєднався до
сьогоднішнього
вебінару тема дуже актуальна ми бачимо
це по ваших реєстраціях наразі бачимо
понад 5 000 реєстрацій вони продовжують
летіти тому розуміємо що це дуже важлива
тема зараз під час війни АА І дійсно
дуже важливо наразі вміти піклуватися
про власне здоров'я і ми раді що ця тема
настільки відгукується вам із вітальним
словом Я запрошую до нас Ігоря
хворестяного генерального директора
директорату шкільної освіти Міністерства
освіти та науки
України Ігорю включіть будь ласка
звук
прошу техніків допомогти включити
звук о є Дякую щиро
е Добрий день шановне
товариство нещодавно в межах форуму
перших Леді та джентльменів було
презентовано дослідження яке засвідчило
що в 11 країнах і в Україні зокрема
ментальне здоров'я викликає у людей таку
таку саму стурбованість як бідність
Кліматичні зміни зростання цін учасники
дослідження зазначили що ментальне
здоров'я в наступні п'ять і навіть
більше навіть впродовж наступних 20
років залишатиметься одним із найбільших
викликів людства і варто зауважити що в
умовах війни постійних тривог ментальний
добробут стає ще важливішим а вміння
потурбуватися про себе і допомогти
своєму оточенню Це ті важливі навички
які потрібно опановувати вже змалечку
саме тому я надзвичайно радий що в
тісній співпраці Міністерства unicef
junніor всеукраїнської програми тияк ми
вже другий рік поспіль організовуємо
вебінар щоб нагадати про важливість
ментального здоров'я і турботи про нього
через прості практики маємо на меті
навчити дітей і дорослих уміння
опіклуватися про себе і як я я вже
сказав такий вебінар відбувається вдруге
Міністерство ми всі раді такій традиції
збиратися кожного 10-го жовтня щоб
нагадати і собі і іншим про важливість
турботи про свій психологічний стан про
те що вчитися справлятися з щоденними
викликами які ставить перед нами війна
надзвичайно важливо то рік 10 жовтня
Росія завдала одного з наймасовіших
ракетних ударів по Україні були по ж
далі були великі руйнування багато
українців залишилося без
електропостачання було тривожно
здавалося б тоді зовсім було не час
говорити про ментальне здоров'я і тим
паче проводити флешмоби проте озираючись
назад Сьогодні ми розуміємо що таки
варто і нагадали нам про це саме ви
освітяни адже саме ви у шкільних
укриттях у сховищах дитячих садочків і
підвалах вчили дітей як турбуватися про
себе попри все ви навіть встановили
національний рекорд і ми безмежно вдячні
вам за вашу
роботу цьогоріч плануємо новий флешмоб з
хештегом руханка сили щоб наш торішній
результат покращити а той перевершити і
підтвердити що з кожним роком все більше
і більше людей вчиться турбувати про
свій ментальний стан а допоможе наму
цьому як і Минулого року неперевершена
Світлана Ройс і я певно Як і всі ви з
нетерпінням чекаю зустрічі з нею Дякую
всім
натхненного
заходу Ігор щиро дякую вам за натхнення
для наших освітян А І запрошую до слова
нашу дитячу сімейну психологіню яка Ну
як на мене завжди всі хто бачить і
дивиться завжди кажуть що вона
випромінює світло е і це дійсно
підтверджує її ім'я е Запрошуємо до
слова Світлану
Ройс Доброго дня родино ті з ким ми
знайомі знають що кожну свою зустріч 24
лютого я починаю Саме так Доброго дня
родино Мене звуть Світлана Ройс я дитяча
сімейна психологиня вірна подруга дітей
батьків та освітян і я з вдячністю до
вашої роботою завжди щиро з вами
Минулого року саме в цей день ми
говорили про ментальне здоров'я про те
якими словами говорити про нього з
дітьми і як самим зрозуміти що ж це таке
бо термін та поняття для багатьох нове а
важливість нашого стану важливість того
як ми маємо про нього дбати саме під час
війни стала дуже актуальною бо Від цього
залежить наша стресостійкість і
стійкість дітей нагадаю що за
визначенням з ментальне здоров'я - це
стан фізичного душевного і соціального
добробуту при якому людина може
реалізувати власні здібності
протистояти звичайним життєвим стресом
продуктивно працювати і робити внесок в
суспільне життя це коли наші емоції дії
думки тілесні відчуття усвідомлені
злагоджені керовані коли ми здатні
розвиватися і підтримувати близькі
стосунки коли ми відчуваємо сенс і
реалізацію коли ми вміємо брати
відповідальність і приймати рішення коли
ми реалізуємо свій потенціал і можемо
витримати навантаження та стрес і
адаптуємося до нової реальності коли ми
в контакті з життєвістю навіть в
найскладніші
часи зараз час говорити про
стресостійкість і зміцнювати нашу
стресостійкість ми знаємо що
стресостійкість - це продукт ризику
негараздів та адаптації подолання вона
буває вродженою а буває і набутою вона
не з'являється в ідеальних умовах але
вона залежить від того наскільки ми
можемо усвідомити та витримати досвід з
яким зустрічаємося в теорії
стресостійкості є знання які точно нам
необ необхідні зараз перше ми знаємо що
дитина може витримати навантаження якщо
поруч із нею надійний дорослий дорослий
що дбає в першу чергу про себе і зможе
надати їй підтримку друге є кілька
важливих тем та понять і теорії
стресостійкості поняття активів Кожен з
нас ввійшов війною своїми активами цей
запас фізичних сил і пружності нервової
системи Цей близькість і прив'язаність і
саме відчуття
спорідненості зв'язаності дає нам Стан
безпеки найнебезпечніші часи і ми з вами
пам'ятаємо що коли відбувається щось
критичне діти спочатку дивляться нам в
очі і для них наш погляд буде
опорою вони спираються на наш погляд і
наш спокій а далі для відчуття нашої
стрес стійкості важливо те наскільки ми
втомлені чи енергійні наскільки
відчуваємо всередині себе сили Чи маємо
знання та навички як впливати на
ситуацію чим більше активів тобто
ресурсу було на початку війни тим нам
легше впоратися із навантаженням ризиків
Чи стресорів стресор - це кожен викли
кожна критична ситуація є ще поняття
дози дози
це близкість сила самого стресового
навантаження ми можемо довго з вами
триматися але при довгостривалому стресі
при великій кількості доз та стресорів
навіть найвитриваліші можуть відчути
виснаження складно передбачити яка саме
доза який стресор стане критичним для
нашої нервової системи є ще поняття
модераторів сил що включаються в
допомогу під час стресу це як ка безпеки
в аварійної ситуації на дорозі це і наші
близькі контакти це і гроші це і кризові
втручань що для нас було б важливе перше
зменшити ризики друге відновити зв'язок
з активами чи підвищити рівень активів
та ресурсів і далі подумати що може бути
у нас модератором на жаль ми з вами не
можемо Вплинути саме на ризики та
стресори А ось саме Від
ресурсу залежить чи буде подія такою що
матиме наслідки саме психологічної
травми чи буде тим з чим ми зможемо з
вами впоратись чи витримає наша нервова
система
напругу давайте з вами пригадаємо які
бувають види ресурсів вони бувають
соціальними це стосунки з друзями
родиною та колегами підтримка допомога
від інших людей психологічні ресурси це
розвиток емоційного ту розвиток свого
потенціалу фізичні ресурси харчування
фізична активність сон
відпочинок природні ресурси можливість
перебувати на природі позитивний вплив
кольорів Бачите я сьогодні спеціально
підбирала такий енергічний оптимістичний
колір звуків ароматів природи професійні
ресурси можливість навчатися та
розвиватися в професійній сфері
можливість бути творчим та висловлювати
свої ідеї духовні ресурси релігійні чи
духовні практики які допомагають знайти
спокій та силу та гармонію в нашому
житті але вже по досвіду роботи з
вчителями Я знаю що потрібно говорити не
тільки про загальні ресурси а саме про
дозвіл собі конкретного відпочинку
навіть в найскладніші часи від цього
буде залежати наша стійкість Стан нашого
ментального здоров'я віди відпочинку
фізичний це і сон і їжа і прогулянки і
гімнастика і масаж і рух ментальний
відпочинок
побути подалі від роботи цей цифровий
детокс і можливість Не приймати в якийсь
час складні рішення творчий відпочинок
будь-які творчі дії соціальний
відпочинок відпочинок від соціальних
контактів у кожного з нас у нервової
системи є своя можливість витримати
навантаження контактам чи приємні
контакти емоційний відпочинок це наше
хобі це близькі контакти це творчі дії
це прогулянки і
подарунки і насправді це не просто наше
право це наша протидія стресу це внешок
внесок в наш
добробут і саме зараз ми з вами
спробуємо зробити кілька
практик сядьте разом зі мною в позу
відновлення якою саме зараз може бути
поза вашого
відновлення мені хочеться
спертися на спинку стільця якою буде
ваша поза і далі ми робимо найпростішу
вправу яка дозволяє повернути відчуття
контролю та вплинути на нервову систему
ви знаєте що такі вправи так працюють
саме дихальні вправи ми будемо з вами
казати слова на вдох на вдих Ми кажемо
знаю що вдихаю на видих знаю що
видихаю
вдих і всередині себе ви кажете знаю що
вдихаю
видих знаю що видихаю і ще раз
знаю що вдихаю
знаю що видихає коли ви не знаєте що
робити коли за велика тривога і розпач
Почніть з цього це не просто вдих і
видих не просто дихальна практика це
можливість повернути собі відчуття
контролю ми починаємо повертати собі це
знаю з найпростіших дій і далі ми робимо
вдих і на
видисі Опустіть
плечі
Ми всі з вами помічаємо що наші плечі
зараз підняті це ознака того що наша
м'язова система теж знаходиться в стані
стресу стреси Наші м'язи від хронічного
стресу спазмовані піднімаючи плечі ми
одночасно підтягуємо вгору діафрагму А
вона стискає нижню частину легень і
обсяг легень значно зменшується і діти і
дорослі так і кажуть Я не можу вдихнути
і не можу видихнути спостерігайте будь
ласка за своїми плечими розслаблю м'язи
ми впливаємо і на роботу нервової
системи і на відчуття контролю і тепер
ви знаєте що на процес дихання вдих
і на вудисі ми знімаємо себе тягар і
вантаж і тепер наступна вправа запитайте
будь ласка саме зараз що я сьогодні
зробив чи зробила для себе чи ще зроблю
для себе щоб залишатись життєвим
життєвою та
ли це може бути будь-яка проста дія ось
Я сьогодні вирішила бути в жовтому Цей
колір мій енергетизатор він прискорює
обмінні процеси Він дає мені відчуття
натхнення та сил я на нього
спираюсь ви знаєте є такий секрет люди
які страждають на які переживають
депресію нерідко говорять що сприймають
навколишній світ у сірих тонах виялися
виявилося що це не просто психологічний
феномен сірість фарб при депресії має
під собою фізіологічну основу це
висновок німецьких вчені вчених
виявилось що чим сильніше депресивні
симптоми тим слабкіше реагує сидківка
ока на Му на стимуляцію показом
контрастних зображень і ось я намагаюсь
зараз обирати контрастні кольори Щоб
стимулювати свої
рецептори ще я хочу хочу вам
запропонувати практику яка називається
намисто моєї
сили ця практика дозволяє нам зібрати
краплинки намистинки нашого
ресурсу ви можете намалювати намистинки
намисто можете взяти готове можете
уявити його чи створити самі чи з
дітьми і уявіть будь ласка кожну
закінчену справу кожен успіх кожен новий
здобуток кожну дію про яку ми казали
собі я не зможу кожен раз коли ми змогли
стриматися чи взяти під контроль
емоційну реакцію кожного разу коли ми
витримали навантаження кожного разу
важливо Це
відмічати святкувати хоча би просто собі
сказати я
молодець потрібно збирати намисто своєї
сили ми знаємо що наша само цінка під
дією стресу стає дуже вразливою і наша
відчуття спроможності на щось впливати
зараз зменшене але нам так важливо не
відчувати себе жертвами ми збираємо
намисто своєї сили і концентруємо цю
силу Я впевнена що ваше намисе і у
чоловіков і жінок чоловіків і жінок воно
просто величезне і красивий
потужний Минулого року ми починали нашу
руханку присвячену дню ментального
здоров'я словами дбайливо до інших
дбайливо до себе Сьогодні ми починаємо
так в житті де так багато перешкод Я
відчуваю
крила та коріння І на словах крила ми
тягнемося руками в різні сторони
відчуває свій масштаб відчуває розмах
своїх крил і свого потенціа і тягнемося
до сонця головою а
коріння ми відчуваємо і заземлення і
зв'язок з тим що нас в коріні в
реальності і в
стресостійкості і це і наша життєвість і
наші цінності і наша близькість і наша
віра в
перемогу Я впевнена в нашій силі Я
впевнена в нашій міці рада бути з вами і
слава Україні сила нашим крилам і
міцності нашим нашому корінню
Героям
слава Дякую Світлано е за так багато
нового натхнення для нас цього року а я
щиро вдячна і рада що ми всі створюємо
нову традицію для нашої
України для того щоб кожен з нас знав
трошки більше і міг піклуватися про
власне психічне здоров'я АА І власне те
що вже повторювали наші спікери Минулого
року в нас вже відбувався Перший
Всеукраїнський флешмоб до дня
ментального здоров'я а І власне зараз
давайте перед тим як переходити до
другого розділу нашого вебінару А
пригадаємо яким чином
відбувався всеукраїнсь флешмоб
спільнодбай минулого року і зрозуміємо
Які в нас виклики цього року і які
рекорди ми можемо
повити а в часи неспокою та загальної
тривоги значимість психічного здоров'я
зростає в рази саме тому Дитячий фонд
ООН unicef з громадським рухом
Олександра Педана junніors за підтримки
Міністерства освіти та науки України
організували флешмоб спільнодбай на 10
жовтня до Дня психічного здоров'я
провели навчальний вебінар із
психологинею Світланою Ройс для освітян
на якому обговорили Наскільки важливим
зараз є піклування про психічне здоров'я
та проговорили як саме розмовляти про це
з дітьми Вона запропонувала руханку яка
акцентує увагу на тому як важливо дбати
про свій психічний
стан проте 10 жовтня по всій території
України було завдано наймасовішого
початку повномасштабного вторгнення
ракетного удару десятки вбитих та
поранених пошкоджено важливі об'єкти
інфраструктури знеструмлена частина
областей здавалося б не час для
флешмобів проте українські освітяни
неймовірні зі шкільних сховищ укриттів
дитячих садочків і підвалів до нас
почали десятками приходити відеоруханки
десятки сотні А потім і тисячі дітей
онлайн та офлайн приєдналися до флешмобу
попри рекомендації відтермінувати
українські освітяни вирішили
підтримувати дух українців треба тут і
зараз за будь-яких обставин попри
складні часи які зараз переживає наша
країна дітям їхнім батькам та освітянам
важливо опановувати навички які
дозволяють самостійно подбати про себе
та надати собі першу психологічну
допомогу навіть під час перебування в
укритті як результат 4 школярі 179
закладів освіти з 24х областей України
зокрема тимчасово окупованих об'єднали
зусилля та долучились до флешмобу нам
приємно було отримати потужний відгук
від освітян та сотні дитячих відео які
вкотро демонструють що незламність духу
загартовуються ще у дитинстві Дякуємо
всім хто
долучився а отже наразі в нас
зареєстровано на вебінарах вже більше
55тисяч шкіл тому я впевнена що цього
року ми не то що поб'ємо рекорд А ще
набагато років вперед будемо пробувати
його
перебити Я хочу розказати трошки більше
про громадську організацію junніor ми
опікуємося фізичною активністю
дітей у школах розвиваємо уроки
фізкультури і ми розуміємо наскільки
важлива фізична активність в межах
психічного здоров'я це елемент
психічного здоров'я тому ми б хотіли
трошки більше привернути до цього увагу
і тому я хочу запросити рада
сюди нашу вчительку шкіл школи jніор
найкращу вчительку фізкультури juniorors
2021 року за версією Global teacher
prise а
і Наша Оксана Юрків Минулого року так
само була частиною цього рекорду її діти
також робили руханку Тому я прошу Оксану
до слова буду рада якщо ти розповіш і
про вплив фізичної активності на
ментальне здоров'я і власне яким чином
поділитися своїми лайфхаками Як
проводяться ее ну провости кращий урок
для дітей е Я тут зауважу Що в нас е
сьогодні Ну і взагалі до нашого рекорду
можуть приєднуватися не тільки школи а і
дитячі садочки і секції і гуртки А це
може стати просто частиною виховної
години АА тому власне наш спектр дуже
великий а тому е щиро бажаю щоб кожен
зрозумів яким чином можна розказати це
будь-якій віковий
категорії так щиро вітаю усіх Ну
насправді в мене зараз також стресова
ситуація оскільки щоб долучитися сюди це
треба було пройти певні перешкоди але я
дуже рада що я все скажемо так подолала
і я з вами і насправді знаєте я так собі
от зараз аналізую дуже багато всього Е
що вже пройшло все ж таки ми вже живемо
в більш стабільних умовах навіть
психологічно але якщо я перемотаю цей
ролик свій назад і згадаю коли це все
почалось і коли знаєте що з чим я
зіткнулася і кожен з вас я більш ніж
певно бо бачу дуже багато знайомих
обличчі це напевно мені ще більше додає
впевненості це те що наші дітки
залишилися поза кадром тобто дорослі
десь спробували
адаптуватися пробували адаптуватися
самостійно а діти чому я так кажу тому
що я ще паралельно кла класний керівник
і я зрозуміла що мої діти мій клас
котриій як я написала в себе в
соцмережах 2троє багатодіт на мама 23х
діток ще додатково
е вони залишились самнасам зі своїми
страхами зі своїми переживаннями тому що
дорослі десь в відійшли в адаптації
стосовно себе і що ми Знаєте що ми
робили А що ми робили А ми рухалися ми
максимально рухалися ткільки могли
Звісно що як я кажу що і наш ресурс
небезмежний але вчителі це такі
особистості Хвала і честь їм Я кажу я
завжди вклоняюся всім вчителям того що
ми маємо вплив на наших діток дітки нам
довіряють особливо Ну я зараз можливо де
Що скажу де так але я завжди так кажу
вчителі фізичної культури вони
надособливі того що вчителі фіскультури
мають ту довіру більш Ну ми ближче до
них саме тою руховою активністю про яку
я зараз буду говорити того що діти
хочуть рухової активності діти Хоча є і
такі моменти тоже думаю що кожен зі мною
згодиться що є такі моменти коли треба
десь мотивувати наших діток того що не
Всі розуміють для чого нам це потрібно
тому е ну це все в наших всі Козарі в
наших руках я більш ніж впевна що кожен
З вас може розказати свої лайфхаки свої
зараз я хочу свого досвіду поділитися
своїм і е знаєте що я вже бачу також що
багато моїх лайфхаків користуються інші
вчителі і я дуже рада того що це круто Я
також використовую ваші лайфхаки і це
класно коли ми такки робимося родина от
як сказала Світлана Ройс насправді ми
родина і ми всі коли в тандемі будемо
працювати ми швидше досягнемо Перемоги
того що для чого пацани воюють там як я
завжди кажу якщо ми тут будемо впускати
наше майбутнє і Отже Ну я б зараз
напевно найбільше хотіла сказати Як я
мотивую своїх діток до рухової
активності того що це не так легко це
всі напевно знають Це вже такий прям
традиційний мій флешмоб Це мій
фітнес-батл котрий Я кажу крокуємо
впевнено Тепер я вже його назвала до
перемоги і дітям це заходить особливо
знову ж таки скажу вік до більше
заходить до восьмого класу ну це свого
досвіду вони е включають свої гаджети
вони вмикають свої е фітнес-браслети і
вони відповідно е хочуть побільше
руховий н знаєте як до мене тепер от
крайнього разу п'ятикласниця до мене
підійшла дівчинка і каже Оксана
Романівна А я находила на мій бенд Тобто
це дитина ну В нас є свої знаєте це
також я не можу сказати всім але в мене
це працює ми дійсно знаходимо спонсорів
ми даруємо дітям мібенди за те що вони
роблять рекорди в нас рекорд 100 000
кроків за добу ну тобто за це це є
досить велика і Повірте коли батьки
дзвонять до тебе того що є різні моменти
але коли батьки дзвонять і кажуть Оксан
майна що ви з ними робите Що вони навіть
їсти е їдять ходячи ходячи тобто вони не
зупиняються тобто до чого я це веду що
якщо ми їх вмотивуємо вони знайдуть
можливості знайдуть Ба ну тобто основна
ціль наша їх зацікавити там десь якийсь
придумати свій лайфхак я більш ніж
впевнена що кожен з нас має такі
лайфхаки і я користуюся вашим Ми також
але до чого я хочу сказати що ми знаємо
оцю нашу теорію і це що нам рекомендує
вос що е діти п'ять пяти від пти до 17
років мають мати рухову активність не
менше 60 хвилин в день Це не так багато
насправді це не так багато того що якщо
ти їх мотивуєш то рухова активність
котра зробила 100 000 кроків це було 19
годин рухової активності протягом дня
Тобто вона ходила і ходили вони рухалися
вони бігали ну швидше повільніше Слава
Богу що зараз Ці програмки дають
можливість навіть роз хувати ну яка
активність саме була Тому я все ж таки
хочу вас закликати
і Ну якось навіть не знаю мотивувати
своїм прикладом що давайте ми все ж таки
Для нас це дуже важливо наші діти це є
наше майбутнє ми заради них перемагаємо
ми заради них десь перезавантажуємось
самостійно того що вчителі Також
виснажуються ми також люди але треба
дітям пояснювати розумієте коли вони
зрозуміють Що Що Це для них важливо вони
знайдуть свої можливості і зараз я б
хотіла ще сказати ще один такий тоже ну
скажемо так лайфхак свого досвіду
стосовно того що мотивації важливо свій
приклад демонструвати собою Тобто з ними
йти на всі що Круто заходить tiktok ну
знову ж таки тут є прибічники і є
можливо противники є різні питання але в
мене це працює Ми запускаємо різні
челенджі флешмобі ми доєднуємося до
джуніорса ми завжди працюємо десь в
таких
активних в активностях щоб їм це було
цікаво вони можуть прибігти до мене і
сказати мені оксанма давайте дуже
класний є челендж правда це більш
спортивного завжди спрямування Вони
знають що до мене з челенджами треба
бігти руховими челенджами не з якимось
там хоча інколи буває що бачу що і
вчителі знімають всякі тренди А чому
тренди Зараз я вам тоже скажу того що
щоб бути в тіктоці десь відомим потрібно
і долучатися до трендів і знову ж таки я
вірю в те що оця сьогоднішня руханка Я
десь частково можливо і хвилюються але я
справляюся надіюсь що я справлюся з цим
всім е ця руханка можливо тоже буде
нашим трендом чому я завжди кажу знаєте
що я хочу я хочу щоб tiktok став
спортивною платформою рухової активності
Ну не прям спорт великих досягнень
мається на увазі щоб не були там всякі
смішні відеоролики А щоб наша рухова
активність заполонила tiktok ну це моя
така мрія Я не знаю надіюсь що ми до неї
таки спрямуємо і все ж таки наш tiktok
не буде десь лише платформа для сміху а
хоча там тоже є дуже круті дуже круті є
лайфхаки якими я і сама ділюся і сама
черпаю А зараз я б напевно Марі Я так
думаю що я достатньо сказала стосовно
свого досвіду хто ще може Я завжди люблю
працювати так практично бо ми вчителі
практики можете в чатах прописати свої
лайфхаки це дуже круто вони збережуться
і ми будемо мати можливість ними
скористатися А зараз все ж таки я б
хотіла Приступити до нашої рух до нашої
нової так ну оголосити впер так так
абсолютно Я погоджуюся так все ж такий
таймінг завжди так Настав
час показати і розказати нову руханку і
я буду вдячна Якщо зараз всі хто до нас
доєднаний а через Zoom включить свої
камери і ми зможемо показати всіх і
разом вивчити нашу нову
руханку сили е це наш хештег цього року
руханка сили можете запам'ятовувати але
потім ми про це детально розкажемо вже
про механіку пізніше ну а
наразі прошу долучатись прошу також
долучатись всіх хто нас дивиться в
YouTube трансляція Facebook
трансляції теж до виконання цих рухів
тоді буде простіше їх вже показувати
вашим дітям так і знову ж таки я
продовжу і прокачаємо свою пам'ять бо
Повірте ці словечка які я отримала Їх
вивчити це вже круто Тобто ми також
маємо себе тренувати бо не завжди ну наш
цифровий сцвіт інколи скажемо так
обмежує нас в цьому тому Давайте я зараз
всеж таки приступлю до слів ми повто
римо ці слова помало тоді ми їх
підкріпимо рухами Отже слова в нас такі
в житті де так багато перешкод Я
відчуваю крила та коріння слова я можу
мій таємний код і моя сила сяєму
проміння мій розум тіло творчість
почуття мої натхнення радість мрії
близькість в моїх руках будую я моє
життя і відчуваю впевненість та
стійкість багато слів правда багато Але
я думаю що ми все ж таки їх подолаємо ми
їх вивчимо ну зрештою це буде домашнє
завдання ми опрацюємо і Звісно що з
дітками будемо їх вивчати До речі з
дітками дуже класно знову ж таки я ще
коротко скажу свій лайфхак по слову
Кожен з нас тоже класно заходить і
швидше вивчається це вже така групова
робота Давайте я ще раз напевно Марія
повторю раз слова і тоді вже підкріплю
підкріплю рухами в житті й де так багато
перешкод Я відчуваю крила та коріння
слова я можу мій таємний код і моя сила
сяєму в проміння мій розум тіло
творчість почуття моє натхнення радість
мрії близькість в моїх руках будую я
нове моє життя і відчуваю впевненість і
стійкість Отже хто сидить можна сидячи
можна стоячи тобто тут руханка така що
дозволяє
е в своїх комфортних умовах її
повторити в житті де так багато
перешкод
ця трансляція добре добре
видно Так я я відчуваю крила та
коріння слова я можу мій таємний код і
моя сила сяє
мовпроміння мій розум тіло творчість
почуття моє натхнення радість мрії
близькість в моїх руках
будую я нове моє життя і відчуваю
впевненість та стійкість правда
нескладно До речі якщо рухи вже
повторюються Словами воно набагато легше
запам'ятовується давайте ще раз
повторимо думаю що так бачу що є
схвальні кивки головою в житті де так
багато
перешкод Я
відчуваю Я
відчуваю крила та
коріння слова я можу мій таємний
код і моя сила ця є мов проміння мій
розум тіло творчість
почуття в
мо моє натхнення радість мрії близькість
в моїх руках будую я моє життя і
відчуваю впевненість та стійкість Ура я
справдилася я відчуваю тактіки
впевненість та стійкість там трошечки
Звісно що я ну хвилювання знову ж таки
Су
стікість дякую Дуже дякую Дуже всім я на
всяк випадок скажу що трошки пізніше ми
покажемо з Олександром Педаном цю
руханку яку ви зможете вже повторювати
разом з ним Тому не хвилюйтесь зараз не
треба типу не не підвищуємо тривожність
бо ми про ментальне здоров'я Все далі
буде
е Я ще Оксана дуже попрошу розказати як
минулого року е проводила ти сам урок да
оцю там або виховну го годину і яким
чином цього року що в нас є новенького
для того щоб розказати це дітям і
презентувати тому що Звичайно що якщо ми
просто візьмемо і зробимо з ними цю
руханку то навряд чи вони зрозуміють
щось про ментальне здоров'я е тому яким
чином про це говорити з дітьми так щоб
вони усвідомили це так дивіться звісно в
в першу чергу Ну щоб просто повторити
рухи це не не варіант Ну так це буде
якась може своя мінімально рухова
активність без користі але коли дітки
усвідомлюють те що ее про для чого їм це
потрібно це зовсім по-іншому
сприймається Я особисто з своїми дітьми
на таких довірливих відносинах насправді
і ми саме основне що я їм пояснюю що
Знаєте в нас я завжди їм кажу дітки от
болить у вас рука Так ви там лікуєте
ручку ножку бо що А от коли в нас емоції
це дуже важливо і вони такі дивляться на
мене Очи ну знаєте ми завжди так дітки
розуміють що наприклад як щось дотичне
де ти можеш зрозуміти а щось таке от
воно ну захварне його не побачиш і тому
я це з ними так
проговорюю щоб вони щоб вони мені більше
Ну я завжди я Я дуже Люб одна Зараз я
вам як сплклас завжди люблю щоб чути
фідбек от от вони мені пояснюють Тобто
ми з ними щоразу це е проговорю
проговорюємо як вони це розуміють тоді я
їх націлюю ну більшість більшість основа
все ж таки розуміють це правильно але і
бувають моменти коли потрібно десь е це
легенько спрямувати в те русло яке нам
потрібно А зараз взагалі дуже круто
знаєте і дуже я тішуся тим що ми не одні
і що в нас є насправді е є люди які
дбають навіть і про на наш нам
допомагають і цього року це взагалі
круто спрацювало е де вже були готові е
розробки уроків думаю що більшість з вас
напевно так більшість з вас скористалися
вже цими уроками і насправді там класно
поділено для молодшої для молодшої ланки
і для ее старшокласників скажемо так і Я
дуже тішуся тим що насправді е-е Ну
насправді в Та от про те що я починала
свій виступ що в тандемі нам це набагато
легше е освоїти і набагато легше донести
це дітям в такій Ну не невимушеній формі
Я завжди більш такий кажу Я більше
ділюся з дітьми таких товариських
відносин напевно більшість з нас так і
працює того що зараз такий час і
насправді так нас ну зобов'язує напевно
реалії нашого сьогодення це та
коротенько Марія розказала ну стосовно
що а я думаю що ти ще
доповниш детальніше де саме знайти Так
бо я
абсолютно Давайте я Я дуже дякую Я дуже
дякую всім хто повторював тут ви вже
великі молодці Ви вже знаєте цю руханку
і це дуже важливо Я дуже дякую всім хто
це повторював трансляції А я хочу
сказати що всі документи матеріали відео
ми все відправимо вам на ту електронну
адресу яку ви вказали власне при тому
коли ви реєструвалися на вебінар Тому
зараз не треба швидко записувати за
Оксаною все буде надіслено не
переживаємо за це а отже Я тепер готова
і дуже рада перейти вже до механіки
самого всеукраїнського флешмобу щоб ми
точно нічого не пропустили і все
розказали далі якщо будуть ще питання То
ми будемо готові
відповідати на них ну там да якщо вони
будуть якщо вони залишаться ще раз
повторюю що це великий Всеукраїнський
флешмоб який організований міністерством
освіти та науки України дитячим фондом
ООН юicef України громадською
організацією рух олексаandдра Педана
jiorс і за сприяння всеукраїнської
програми ментального здоров'я ти як А
власне Тепер я готова поділитися з вами
своїм вже екраном і розказати більше про
то як проводити сам флешмоб а-а е-е Отже
10 жовтня ми святкуємо Всеукраїнський
флешмоб до дня ментального здоров'я е це
е саме той день який визначений
всесвітній День ментального Здоров'я е
як взяти участь у самому флешмобі і як
він називається руханка сили ми вас
Будемо знаходити в будь-яких соціальних
мережах саме по цкому хештегу руханка
сили А у флешмобі можуть брати участь як
цілі клас групи так і якась частина з
них це може бути якась команда або
колектив а І власне це може бути як
школа так і клас так і гурток
секція дитячий садок абсолютно Вам
вирішувати на яку аудиторію Ви готові
працювати і з якою аудиторією ви
працюєте е ви можете це робити як в
офлайн навчанні в приміщенні закладу
освіти так і через групу вий відеочат
будь-який це от Як ви працюєте зазвичай
з вашими дітками так власне і тут ви
можете так само продовжувати працювати
організатором флешмобу на місцях можуть
стати як вчителі вихователі педагоги
шкільні психологи вчителі організатори
так і керівництво закладу тобто знову ж
таки ми розуміємо що вам на місцях
видніше і зрозуміліше як як ліпше це
провести а важливо Да так як ми
встановлюємо національний рекорд кожна
дитина може взяти участь у флешмобі
тільки один раз тому власне це те що
треба запам'ятати Ну що там ми не можемо
бігати Ну там і записувати і викладати
один
раз Ну тих самих типу команду декілька
разів
АА на який саме план ми пропонуємо для
проведення такого заходу на 10 жовтня ня
це провести для дітей підлітків або
молоді урок про День ментального
Здоров'я з практичними порадами Щодо
його підтримки на основі запропонованих
нами матеріалів вони будуть трошки нижче
ми зможемо вами з вами поділитися ними
ще раз якщо хтось буде дивитися В запису
цей вебінар то обов'язково не забудьте
зареєструватися тоді ми вас побачимо і
зможемо переслати всі матеріали
а далі важливо з дітками вивчити разом
руханку ми розуміємо що в нас тут можуть
бути там прямо малеча з дитячого садочку
тоді це може ее ну розказувати сам
віршик може наприклад вихователь а дітки
Тільки от запам'ятали ці рухи і вони
повторюють і це вже супер класно і ви
можете Та так Таким чином працювати із
ними записати руханку на відео так щоб
було видно всіх учасників флешмобу знову
ж таки повер вертаємося до рекорду якщо
ми його хочемо разом з вами
зафіксувати то Важливо щоб потім члени
журі могли перерахувати всіх учасників
що там не хтось сховався всі хто
залишаються за кадром ми їх не
рахуємо і вважаємо що вони не брали
участь в цьому
флешмобі власне тут акцент хочемо
зробити я знаю що там багато закладів
освіти вже підпису підписують від
початку роботи з дітками дозвіл від
батьків на показ дітей в соціальних
мережах але просто просимо ще раз
нагадуємо що перед тим як ви викладаєте
в соціальні мережі руханки да Що там
впевненість е Майте впевненість що
батьки
дозволяють власне викладати відео з
дітками в соціальні мережі Ну і власне
після того як ви записуєте руханку Ми
пропонуємо вам її викласти в одну з
запропонованих соціальних мереж будь то
tiktok Instagram або Facebook
обов'язково вказавши назву хештегу
руханка сили за такою руханкою ми
зможемо вас ідентифікувати найти і і
долучити до цього рекорду але е дуже
важливо щоб точно ми вас знайшли і не
загубили для того щоб стати частиною
фіксації національного рекорду виконавши
дії описані вище важливо заповнити
Google форму для фіксації самого рекорду
і неодмінно там буде окрема графа
зазначити кількість дітей що брали
участь у вашій руханці тобто
власне тут Ми сподіваємось що ви
зазначаєте дійсно відповідаль ту
кількість яка там існує але власне в
даній ситуа ції все одно члени жрі далі
будуть перераховувати
їх по долученому лінку на власне ваш
вашу руханку вашого класу або групи
А
далі Зараз я вас от власне ознайомлю з
тим що може стати
частиною
самого вашого уроку присвяченого в цей
день дню ментального здоров'я А ми
нагадуємо що існує всеукраїнський урок з
ментального здоров'я він існує для
перших-шостих класів і для сомих-11-х
класів називається Ти як повертаємося до
школи це всеукраїнський урок про
важливість психічного здоров'я фахівці
максимально доступно розкажуть діткам в
рамках цього уроку як працюють наші
емоції покажуть прості вправи для
заспокоєння У стресових ситуаціях
підкажуть Як подолати страхи і
тривожність пов'язани з початком
навчального року Ну і власне вже під час
всього процесу загалом під час
навчального процесу
а власне це допоможе вам легко в
доступній формі розказати дітям про те
як піклуватися про ментальне здоров'я і
в Листі також будуть зазначені інші
джерела з яких ви можете отримувати
додаткову інформацію для роботи з дітьми
щодо поліпшення знань про психічне
здоров'я а-е також в цьому листі надій
для вас записана відеоруханка від
Олександра Педана яку ви можете
відтворити з дітками для участі в
флешмобу а также використати впродовж
навчального року для відпочинку та
переключення уваги під час уроку а в
також в цьому листі буде посилання на
Google форму для фіксації вашої участі в
національному рекорді і матеріали щодо
ментального здоро зровя які можуть
розповсюдити в межах закладу освіти це
інформаційні ресурси всеукраїнської
програми як психологічні онлайн
консультації танерджайзер для дітей та
підлітків і національно гаряча лінія для
дітей та молоді
ластрада важлива тут на всяк випадок Ми
цю презентацію надішлюмо вам
також вона додасть вам розуміння як
підготуватися до цього уроку і власне
ось в кінці буде Останній наш слайд який
за бажанням ви можете роздрукувати І
повісити як в межах класу так і в межах
там в холі наприклад вашого закладу
освіти це дасть можливість дітям які або
не потрапили з якоїсь причини на урок
потім мати можливість в подальшому
ее
познайомитися
знайти аптечку психологічної
самодопомоги або записатися на
онлайн-консультації від tiner jйer або
власне скористатися гарячою лінією для
молоді та підлітків
е це все буде у вас в вашому доступі для
вашого використання і
власне ви самостійно зможете приймати
рішення що використовувати що ні ми зі
свого боку даємо максимальну кількі
якість варіацій Да щоб цей урок для вас
пройшов комфортно і в першу чергу
комфортно і зрозуміло пройшов для ваших
дітей а ну і наостанок я би залюбки е з
вами ще раз показала де буде
лежати наша руханка е руханка сили е я
попрошу випустити її зараз з Ютуба і ще
раз ми я думаю на останок з з Можемо її
з вами повторити за нашим лідером руху
jніо Олександром Педаном Ну і власне
просто зрозуміти де іїї знайти 10 жовтня
або Якщо раптом 10 жовтня ви не
встигнете це зробити то я думаю що там
цілий тиждень ми можемо надати для того
щоб ви
встигли власне зробити урок ментального
здоров'я з дітьми записати руханку і
викласти в соціальні мережі підводити
остаточні підсумки ми будемо в кінці
тижня Отже прошу на екран нашу
руханку житті де так багато перешкод Я
відчуваю крила та коріння слова я можу
мій таємний код і моя сила сяє промін
мій розум тіло творчість почуття моє
натхнення радість мрії
близькість в моїх руках будую я моє
життя і відчуваю впевненість Та
спіль я дякую всім
дуже за цей неймовірний вебінар Я дуже
прошу вас не забувати що ви повинні
піклуватися про власне ментальне
здоров'я щоб допомагати іншим ми завжди
кажемо нагадуємо як як да в стюардеси в
літаках кажуть спочатку одягаємо маску
собі а потім своїм дітям е тому дуже
просимо піклуйтеся сумі у вас тепер є
поради від нашої дитячої сімейної
психологійні Світлани Ройс допомагайте
своїм дітям опанувати
знання про ментальне здоров'я і тим як
вони можуть допомогти ти
собі на всякй випадок питаю чи в нас є
питання зараз кажуть що якісь є зараз
секундочку
спробуємо відповісти на них
чи можна додавати рухи Ні це в нас от є
такий
флешмоб і він тому і флешмоб що всі
виконують однакові
дії так щоб ну це було реально
всеукраїнським однаковим флешмобом але
це не означає що ви не можете придумати
свої рухнки і свої рухи і також
придумати їх але це не буде частиною
вже ну саме всеукраїнського флешмобу да
руханка сили А це буде ваш власний вклад
в розвиток ваших дітей і ну абсолютно
точно що ви можете це робити просто це
вже не буде в межах цього
всеукраїнського флешмобу
А так дивимось дальлі скільки людей зі
школи класів груп можуть брати участь
хоч всі власне ее Ну ми пам'ятаємо в нас
Минулого року був заклад якщо не
помиляюся з нього брало участь
476 осіб дітей а власне це була
вчителька організаторка Дякуємо вам дуже
якщо ви сьогодні дивитесь і будете брати
участь і цього року власне яким чином це
відбувалося кожен клас знімав окремо
руханку а потім вчителька змонтувала це
ну в таку типу єдиний ролик який вже
виклала і там Ну дійсно було дуже багато
людей Ну от Якщо я не помиляюся це було
476 АА я бачу ще одне питання У нас в
зум-трансляції е
не знаю Зараз я
дивлюся чи можуть брати
участь лише
педколектив я думаю що можуть тому що
насправді ми ну
підтримуємо ментальне здоров'я у всіх і
це також дуже
важливо а бачу що питань начебто більше
немає Якщо раптом вони з'являться то у
ми зараз надішлемо вам
інформацію на електронну пошту якщо її
буде недостатньо то там буде контактна
особа яка буде готова відповідати вам на
всі питання але пожалійте її спочатку
Прочитайте весь лист бо вас дуже багато
насправді досі продовжується реєстрація
і вона вже перевила за 6 000 людей я
бачу ще одне питання але ну піднімається
рука Можливо ви напишете в чаті питання
бо я на жаль не ну не бачу
вас поки ви пишете в чаті бачу ще одне
питання чи можуть з дітьми брати участь
педагоги чи ввійдуть вони в число
рекорду так вони ввійдуть важливо тільки
пам'ятати що ну всі учасники яких будуть
рахувати вони повинні бути у відео видні
ну тобто ви не можете себе реєструвати
учасником якщо ви знімали наприклад
тобто учасники Це ті яких ми можемо
парахувати по Головах в
кадрі Ну тому Звичайно що ми розуміємо
що кожен хоче там я же теж брав участь
але тоді я не знаю тоді міняйтесь потім
місцями і так щоб вас було видно
окремо більше поки що не бачу
питань тому я всім щиро Бажаю гарного
вечора берегти себе берегти своє власне
ментальне здоров'я і допомагати це
робити вашим діткам щиро бажаю
встановлення нам нового національного
рекорду Ну і власне до зустрічі
тримаємося разом Слава
Україні